recursive data play a key role in
programming so let's take a mathematical
look at what goes on so the basic idea
of recursive data is roughly that you're
going to define a class of objects in
terms of the simpler versions of the
same object a little bit more precise
with a little more precision what we can
the idea is that you can build up a
recursive data type by starting with
some stuff that you understand it's not
recursive and you give me some base
objects that I can begin with and
declare that they belong to this
recursive datum and then you give me
some rules called constructor rules
which enable me to build new objects of
the recursive type by applying these
constructors to objects that I've
already built up there's nothing
circular about it because I'm always
building up new stuff from stuff I
already have let's look at an example
I'm going to define a set E that's a
subset of the integers and I'm going to
give you a recursive definition of E the
base case is that I'm going to tell you
the zeroes in E and I'm going to give
you two constructors the first one says
that if you have an end that's in E you
can add two to it and get a new element
in E providing that n is non-negative
the second constructor is that if you
have an N that's an E you can negate it
you can take - n providing that n is
positive and those are the two
constructor rules well let's look at
what goes on here what is this telling
us well let's just use the first
constructor rule and use it repeatedly I
can start off with zero that's the base
case and then I can apply the
constructor to add 2 to it then I can
apply the constructor again to add to
add 2 to 0 plus 2 and then I can apply
the third time to get add 2 to 0 plus 2
plus 2 and it's clear what I'm getting
is 0 2 4 6 and so on
and I'm gonna get all of the
non-negative even numbers in that way ok
now I can apply to these the positive
numbers I can apply the negation
constructor so I can get minus 2 minus 4
minus 6 and it becomes apparent then
that I can get all of the even numbers
okay so we just figured out that it
contains the even numbers is there
anything else in E and the answer is no
and the reason is that a part of an
implicit part of the understanding of a
definition like this is that the only
way that things can get into E is by
being a base case or by being
constructed from previously constructive
ament's by applying to construct the
rules in other words there's an implicit
clause here that says that's all that
implicit clause is called the extremal
clause and it's taken for granted and
rarely mentioned explicitly as part of a
recursive definition but it's always to
be understood okay let's look at a so
what we can conclude from this is that E
is exactly the even integers because
there's nothing else there except that
the one that those ones that were built
up in the way indicated so let's look at
a slightly more interesting example now
I wanted to find the set of strings that
consists solely of left and right
parenthesis as such that the left and
right parenthesis match up well writing
parenthesis on this light turns out to
be confusing with parentheses that are
actually used to delimit things so I'm
gonna replace parentheses by brackets in
below right bracket and a left bracket
this notation here by the way stands for
the set of finite strings of right and
left brackets it's a general notation if
you have some collection of objects
which you think of as letters and you
write an asterisk as a superscript that
means the finite strings of those
letters so these are the finite strings
of right and left brackets and I want to
give a recursive definition of a set M
which I plan will be precisely those
strings where the left and right
brackets match up appropriately the way
to think about matching up is take a say
a standard arithmetic expression
involving plus some times and so on and
make sure that it's fully parenthesized
so whenever you add two things there's
parentheses around that I mean you have
to multiply two things there's
parentheses around that meaning brackets
then if you erase everything
but the brackets what you'd be left with
would be a set of matched brackets
actually it would be a set of match
brackets or you could have several of
them next to each other they those would
still could be considered matched so
that's the way our definition is going
to behave
let's give it okay so the base case is
the but the simplest could be I'm going
to start with the empty string the empty
string is this thing that acts like a 0
under putting strings next to each other
or the concatenation operation if you
concatenate the empty string with any
string it doesn't change the string and
by definition then the empty string is a
string with no characters has length of
0 and it acts as an identity under
putting the strings next to each other
ok there's going to be one constructor
in M that's slightly ingenious there's
other maybe simpler or more natural ways
to make up constructors that would
define m but this one is particularly
nice because I can get away with just
one and it has some nice properties that
we'll explore later so here's the rule
if I've built up two strings s and T of
matched brackets that are in M then I
can build a new one by putting matched
brackets around s and concatenated it
with T that is if s entire strings of
brackets in M then if I start with a
left bracket followed by the brackets in
s followed by a right bracket followed
by the brackets in T that new string is
yet another element that I've built up
in M let's practice this to see how it
works so there's the constructor again
well how do I get started to start well
I have as the base case SNT have to both
be the empty string because that's the
only thing I can applaud the only thing
available to apply the constructor to so
if I do that basically the s and the T
disappear in this constructor expression
and all I'm left with is a matching left
and right bracket all right but now I've
got a matching left and right bracket so
I can use that to apply the constructor
to so I could let s be the matching
brackets and T still be the empty string
now when I plug in to the constructor
the T that still disappears
but I find brackets within brackets and
that's another string that I've built up
in M now I could also be being
methodical I could let s be empty and T
be the brackets and if I do that then
the S goes away and the T becomes the
matched pair of brackets and I wind up
with a matched pair next to a matched
pair then of course I could let both of
them be that matched brackets and then I
get a matched a nested pair next to a
matched pair and now that I've got also
going back to the very beginning the
next most complicated string that I had
was the nested pair of brackets I could
let s be that and T be empty and then I
would get brackets nested to depth three
and so on that's the idea all right
now it may or may not be clear that you
get exactly the strings of matched
brackets in this way that's taken up
further in the notes and in some
problems but we're just trying to
understand how this definition works and
take it for granted that in fact it's
right let's use the definition to prove
some things about em but I want to prove
the things based on the definition of M
not assuming that it works as intended
so I'm gonna claim based on the
definition that it's impossible to find
a string in M that starts with a right
bracket now of course since we're
assuming M is the right definition of
matched brackets it's clear that a
string that starts with a right bracket
already has nothing to match it though
no left bracket matching it so it
shouldn't be in there but let's just
make sure that the definition behaves in
the way that we intend or it might be
wrong so how do I prove that no string
in M starts with a right bracket well
let's look at the definition the base
case doesn't have any brackets at all so
it certainly doesn't start with a right
bracket and looking at the constructor
rule all the strings that you can
construct start with a left bracket and
so we're really appealing to the
implicit that's all clause the extremal
clause that says that since the only way
to get things in m is by applying the
constructor
you're not going to be able to get
anything that starts with a right
bracket alright one more example of a
recursively defined data type that's
interesting and we'll be doing some
lovely class problems with is the class
of that I call f-18 functions these are
the functions from a first term of
calculus like as you study in 1801
functions of a real variable real
variable and here's a recursive
definition that I think covers all of
the functions that are considered in
1801 I'm going to start off with the
identity function and any constant
function and the function sine of X and
declare that those are the base cases
those are the functions in F 18 all
right
then here are the constructor rules if I
have two functions that are in F 18 I
can Adam multiply them or take two to
the F where F is in there and those will
all also be functions in F 18 so I can
start building up a bunch of interesting
stuff like polynomials and Exponential's
in addition if I have a function that's
an F 18 I can take its inverse at least
insofar as the inverse is defined in a
function and I can also compose two
functions that are an f-18 to get
another one let's look at how this
definition works I claim that in fact
the function minus X is an f-18 how do I
build up minus X from the rules well
minus 1 is a constant function so I have
that and X is just the identity function
and I can multiply two functions that I
have so if I multiply minus 1 times X
guess what I got minus X so I've just
figured out that that function is an
f-18 what about the square root of x
well if I multiply the identity by
itself I get the function x squared and
then if I take its inverse that's square
root of x ok well I gave you sine X but
not cosine X or any other trig functions
why not well I mean I want them all but
I can get them by the rules already so
how do you get cosine X well saw cosine
X is just sine of X plus
hi well how does why is that in their
pies a constant X is the identity so the
sum is a function that's an f-18 and
then if I compose that function with
sine I get sine of X plus pi which is
cosine X so cosine X is there now I
didn't this was actually pointed out to
me by students this simple way of
getting cosine X the original way that I
thought and I was using that square root
operation where I was going to use the
identity that cosine squared plus sine
squared is equal to 1 so if I take 1
minus sine squared and then take the
square root that's another way to get
cosine X the point being that there's a
lot of ways to derive the same function
as being an f-18 built up from the
operations applied to other functions
what about log of X let's just close
with that how do I get log of X well log
of X is the inverse of e to the X how do
I get e to the X well e to the X is what
you get by taking 2 to the log to the
base 2 of e which is e and then raising
that to the power X so if I take log E
which is a constant log to the base 2 of
a which is a constant I multiplied by X
the identity function and I take 2 to
that power I'm composing in other words
X log X with the function 2 with the
constructor 2 to the F then I wind up
with the function e to the X and when I
take its inverse I get log of X as
claimed